dust off your Gwent decks and wash your
mouth from season eight of Game of
Thrones because we have the first
official trailer for Netflix's The
Witcher and I have to say I'm pretty
excited so in this video we're gonna
take a deep dive into the trailer and
try to figure out what this season is
all about so if you haven't seen it yet
I've left a link in the description
below then come on back before we get
into it there's some new information
that everyone should know about this
season and it comes directly from the
showrunner Lauren hiss rich first the
show will be based more off the books
than the video game and that there will
be no main villain in season 1 like in
Game of Thrones she said characters
you'll come to hate you may find
yourself liking later on and vice versa
and the story will rely heavily on
political intrigue but enough about that
let's get right into this our first shot
is of our protagonist Geralt of Rivia
played by Superman himself Henry Cavill
- that weird mustache removal you see
some of the townspeople take note of him
because witchers aren't that common of
an occurrence even in the dialogue the
narrator says I remember hearing stories
about witcher's we then switch to this
shot of Geralt fighting off a monster in
an abandoned building perhaps a church
or house of nobility
witcher's for those of you who don't
know or essentially monster hunters for
hire and this ties into the next clip
here a bloodied Geralt and what looks
like the same town from the first shot
and a mob in the background
my best guess here is that Geralt has
just defeated a monster that was
plaguing this town
hence the mob or it could be the gang he
fights near the end but I'm still kind
of leaning towards monster because of
the torch-wielding mob now we get a
group of fierce tribal women alongside
our first look at ciri all we know about
her in the Netflix version is that she's
a mysterious young newcomer from royalty
but we'll learn a bit more about her and
what her story is in the clips ahead now
the narration here talks about elves
being the first people in the continent
but these are not elves no pointy ears
and they're all women like some sort of
Amazonian tribe this group here is
likely on the lookout for ciri as we'll
see in a clip later on we see her in
what looks like a powerful screaming
blast attack this is part of an attack
scene we'll get a better look at later
on then we have our first look at the
sorceress yennefer
beside her is her trainer slash teacher
notice also her hand and deformed jaw in
the books she was born as a hunchback
but later on in the trailer she's out on
the battlefield no deformed jaw or hands
so this is either a a dream or vision or
be later on in the season when some sort
of magic has healed her deformities we
have a quick little shot here of Geralt
peering from the rocks which tells us
that this season will expand several
areas of the continent from frozen land
sea sides and jungles this shot occurs
right in the narration explaining how
else taught humans how to turn chaos
into magic and look what happens here is
the trainer levitates the rock the
flower dies hinting that magic in this
world comes at a price could there be a
connection to yennefer and her ailment
we have a mysterious swordsman here and
sheath his sword which looks like it
could be Mahesh jad whose characters
Wilk affords I'm sorry if I'm saying
that wrong who is a commander of the
mages now it might not be since the
character usually with staff but not
much is known at this point here we have
more evidence that political palace
intrigue will play a big role in this
season as a giant mace wielding knight
attacks and behind him are royal
subjects
just as he swings down we get this shot
of woman screaming and considering
there's another attack on innocents
later on in the trailer I doubt this
season will be low on the massacres now
here's another interesting shot this man
over here is the one in the narration
talking all about the history of elves
human and magic right alongside yennefer
this is is 'tried one of yennefer
long-time lovers who will later come
into conflict with Geralt now look at
the skulls in the background hinting
that they're in some sort of crypt or
place where dark magic could be
practiced this gorgeous shot here I
believe is the show's rendition of our
tuza
a magical academy for young ladies
situated next to the Garstang on Thanet
island this is followed by yennefer x'
teacher looking like she's lecturing a
class of young women who have rocks and
flowers before them just like we saw her
with her shot earlier on here we see
Suri a little roughed up with snow
behind her so her journey is going to
take her many different places and here
we have a giant bonfire where we can see
the house banner of sintra this is
followed but what I assume is some sort
of secret meeting notice how all of them
are holed
and cups so they may be making some sort
of pact here and at the same time the
narration here is talking about control
this is followed by yennefer smashing
the mirror with her reflection and that
probably upset at her own physical
appearance and inability to change it
but the lighting and atmosphere here
suggests this takes place in the same
location as that prior meeting now we
have this gruesome sight and there are a
few things here to take note of first
the shields with the kingdom of Lyria
emblem leery is one of these smaller
northern kingdoms now check out how all
the blood from the corpses lead to the
carriage I can't make out who these two
are here one looks like she could be
holding a baby but it's likely whatever
caused this was a powerful magical user
note there are no signs of non Leiria
fighters here another shot of Geralt
from that same abandoned building from
the beginning on some sort of mission
and yet another shot of him in a
picturesque forest here's that same
building again but now we get a closer
look at the monster who looks like he
could use a manicure now we get our
first look at Triss Merigold who's a
sorceress from tameria she's lecturing
Geralt on only wanting to kill monsters
and get money notice the blue liquid
implants in the background which may
mean she's helping him heal up and then
holy crap my man Gerald has been getting
swole damn but besides the muscles it
looks like he's bandaged up so he
definitely gets badly injured and the
person to heal him is likely Tris here's
Geralt collecting whatever item he was
tasked to get from that abandoned
building likely right before being
ambushed by the monster in this scene we
are back in sintra at what appears to be
a knighting ceremony we know this by the
sintra banners on the side the same
house emblem we saw burning a few shots
ago Sintra also happens to be located
next to Leiria where we saw all those
soldiers massacred likely meaning that a
lot of this fighting will be taking
place in the northern kingdoms the woman
in the middle is Queen Kallen who will
see a bit later on and is the
grandmother of ciri and this is followed
by the narration proclaiming an unknown
girl will be extraordinary which lines
up directly with this shot of ciri and
this to me was the most difficult shot
to decipher suri in the desert next to a
magical tree likely in some sort of
vision tapping into magical energy but
if you have more knowledge about what
this could be I'd love to hear it in the
comments below this is followed by an
AFER's teacher telling her to a
imagine the most powerful woman in the
world where we cut to yennefer without
the Hunchback looking upward at
something probably much bigger than her
whatever it is she's ready her teacher
asked her if she has what it takes then
we see her scream in pain and I'm
wondering if this is some sort of magic
being done to her that might cure her we
get our first look at an absolutely
massive battle with this woman here
maybe possibly the queen of kallen
looking like her side is losing the
battle with a quick cut of a soldier
holding the sintra emblem shield this is
alongside the narration saying she's why
they came so most likely this battle is
being fought over someone not something
and that someone is ciri we have the
same Black Knights destroying and
sacking the town and back to the shot of
ciri blasting everyone away and with the
amount of guards with her swords drawn
here she was probably justified and look
it appears that Geralt is also here we
have a random dude running through the
forest probably occurring a little bit
more to the south and yet another shot
of yennefer who judging by the machine
in the back looks like she could be
tapping into some arcane magic Geralt
gets a pep talk from the same dude he
met earlier and yet another abandoned
building who tells him he can't outrun
destiny and now we have ciri with her
grandmother on her deathbed telling ciri
to find Geralt of Rivia and look what's
being held in the back it's her green
hood which we've seen in her travels
here we see Geralt taking on some gang
members if you've ever played the video
game you'll know this is quite a common
occurrence my guess is this is the same
town from the beginning few shops but at
a different time
I still think he'll takes down these
thugs and probably a monster that's
plaguing this town since I don't see any
of the mob in these later shots a little
silhouette of the monster in the
abandoned house followed by his super
creepy back shot ciri tells her
grandmother she can't do this without
her now if you replay her line here you
can hear a weird distortion in her voice
hinting that when she gets emotional her
powers can take control she'll need to
be trained if she has some crazy magical
powers and wants them under control some
running in the forest by ciri and check
this out this is yennefer behind the
mask here talking to Geralt perfectly
normal looking at what appears to be
Beltane Beltane is a fertility festival
celebrated with food drink and love and
you can tell by the naked people in the
background
some shits going down now we get a bunch
of shots of what appears to be the
battle we saw Syrian from earlier first
we have Geralt fighting people storming
the guards and take a look at this guy
here with the spiky hair who is
definitely not human it's the same guy
here next to ciri
again ciri being caught by these Amazon
girls before their leader comes out and
ciri fleeing under siege with a knight I
don't think it's Geralt here it could be
this dude in the background we have
yennefer screaming using one of her
magic powers or maybe she just cut her
finger cooking and we have her first
shot of Geralt using one of his sign
abilities which are special abilities
witchers can use like knock enemies back
or light them on fire a quick shot of
yennefer x' teacher performing some
lightning magic and directing it out of
a cave and likely near the cliffs where
they trained and of course another huge
ass monster notice that Garrels holding
something in his left hand now look at
his eyes my guess is that this is the
result of him taking a potion or elixir
shortly before battle in the games
taking potions are common before heading
into battle to increase Geralt powers
before certain monster battles
witcher's are the only ones who can
withstand such potions so this makes the
most sense to me so that's the trailer
let me know what you thought and make
sure to LIKE and subscribe because I
plan on doing more Witcher videos as
they come out you can also follow me on
twitter at things story YT and until
next time remember daddy loves you very
much